aloha reject nation it is Greg Alba yeah
and it is John Humphrey veal we're gonna
watch injustice to fighter pack three
reveal trailer can't wait to see whose
revealed in here and by the way patron
add a shout out and I gots a Tony
McGuire since you are a gamer and also
Tony Gill is who I constantly who's
bought talks I beat every time I play
injustice to he never wins he's a loser
Zuzu he's a big loser Tony Tony Tony you
loser
McGwire Tony you're a winner and I love
you is a winner he's the best the
greatest man greatest video games of
colorado's is amazing Wow
he wears an alcohol reference in here
someone's going to smoke - don't lean
too deep fix your posture
[Music]
Chester today people Chester Chester
Chester Chester
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
enchantress you moon in Tantra say
sweet nice sweet
[Music]
yeah that is cool that is way cool
I like how they actually look like the
Ninja Turtles and not those Shrek
creatures yeah
thank goodness holy crap hold on the
wrist rafael's line was too excited I'm
sorry I'm sorry everyone dude Coco rule
I'm sorry I get excited now I'm curious
are you gonna be able to play as all
four at once the turtles are so cool
they all have their distinct
personalities I'm part of injustice is
like the cutscenes before and after I'm
excited to see like the fun little
dialogue they have in there and the
Ninja Turtles in there holy crap I did
not see that coming yeah spider packs
get cooler and cooler they added Hellboy
recently have any the turtles in there
that's a really nice nostalgic surprise
my friends this is the ultimate place
for your nerd matchup yeah only you can
start getting some Marvel characters
Tony Gill you're watching the gamer if
you're watching my friend I am going to
own your
you
all right
yeah be weary of that uh Raphael is the
coolest one but Michelangelo will have
the funniest cutscenes I can't wait but
feeling Leonardo will probably be the
best one to play with es swords they're
probably the best one well yeah and I
feel like nunchucks are always like cool
in theory but harder in practice and I
don't know like I usually play as
Donatello but I like the stick man
sorry Tony Maguire here's your shout out
buddy
you beautiful handsome devil you you are
a devil this man is from one of my
favorite states and all of the US and a
and that is Colorado and Tony McGuire he
told me about his mom I think I
mentioned this in his last shout out but
his mom sounds super hot so I'm really
hoping that Tony if you just pass this
video along your mom I'm in a
relationship
your mom's evidently in a relationship
so I'm thinking though that if she's
cool with it it's my girlfriend's cool
with it your mom and I can make
something cool happen a little bit of
cool hwhip I hope you still stay part of
our patreon Tony in all sincerity I
don't know if you play this game if you
do cool if you play this game I think
there's online play we should verse each
other buddy because this is one of the
few video games that when I get behind
the controller I'm a threat and Tony I'm
threatening you right now I will take
you down McGuire somehow his name looks
like Tobey macGuire yeah famous Hawk
Tober Scott subscribe to the real
rejects please click that notification
bell you can follow us on social media
good day America good night